breath of the wilds enormous map of
Hyrule features so many shoutouts to
other games from super iconic places
like Lake Ilia and Death Mountain that
appear in most games to more specific
locations like the temple of time from
ocarina of time or the spring of Earth
from Skyward Sword why these locations
exist all in the same game is another
question and theory and headache
entirely which a lot of Zelda theorists
have already covered myself included but
what I'm gonna talk about in this video
is a specific location from an older
Zelda title and what happened to it
prior to the events of breath of the
wild if you're an explorer like myself
or like most of the players of breath of
the wild then when it comes time for you
to venture to the Gerudo region of the
Southwest it won't be long before you
come across some specific ruins hidden
away beneath the sands of the vast
desert to be honest these ruins wouldn't
really be hailed as anything that
special but then their name pops up on
the screen the two words that appear are
the arbiters grounds but what part of
these ruins is supposed to be the
original arbiters grounds from Twilight
Princess and how would such a monumental
desert structure be brought to such a
state of decay I'm here to tell you
there actually might be a fairly dark
reason for its destruction so without
further ado allow me to present what
happened to the arbiters grounds
[Music]
the first thing I'm gonna talk about is
the fact that we can know for certain
this is the same arbiters grounds from
Twilight Princess this may seem like an
obvious point to make but bear with me
because I like to cover all of my bases
to avoid at least a few rage induced
comments anyway there's only ever been
one arbiters grounds other recurring
structures like the temple of time or
even hyrule castle itself differ from
game to game due to any number of
reasons but the arbiters grounds has
never been recurring at least not under
that name but I'm getting ahead of
myself it's also located in the same
region as the original arbiters grounds
the Gerudo desert the various pillars
and arches that you see stone about the
place at first glance really don't
appear to resemble the original dungeon
at all but there are certain
similarities we can acknowledge namely
the aforementioned pillars and arches
which is basically all the arbiters
grounds were made of in Twilight
Princess there are pillars stuck in the
sand
arches leading to staircases and
pathways and even more pillars and more
arches surrounding the actual Coliseum
like mirror chamber if you line up your
sight within the first broken arch and
breadth of the wilds variant you can
tell that aside from the strange
protruding Rock in front of you there
used to be a walkway of sorts right
through here this lines out with the
layout of this walkway from the original
version also the design of the arches
and breadth of the wild do differ from
the arches in Twilight Princess
however it's implied that both were made
by the Garuda with the Twilight Princess
architecture featuring the Gerudo symbol
and the breadth of the wild architecture
featuring Gerudo design patterns it's
possible that various decaying portions
of the arbiters grounds which were
already shown to be in a state of decay
in Twilight Princess were rebuilt prior
to its eventual ruin leading to the
similar style and layout yet differing
architecture we see today in breadth of
the wild so in order to explain the
demise of arbiters grounds we also need
to explore what it is or was in Twilight
Princess the arbiters grounds is a
prison built to house high rules most
ruthless criminals either while they
awaited trial execution or exile to the
Twilight Realm seems like a wonder
the vacation spot but you know summer
plans aside the arbiters grounds
according to various pieces of in-game
lore in Easter eggs and the Hyrule
historia book itself is actually built
on the same grounds as the spirit temple
from ocarina of time and bears very
strong resemblances both being built by
ancestors of the Gerudo the sand goddess
also known as the desert Colossus of
ocarina of time can be seen as a statue
in multiple different locations within
the arbiters grounds including the final
chamber of the mirror as you can see
she's always depicted in an open handed
stance wrapped in a Cobra she's
obviously a pivotal figure in spirit
temple lore and due to her prominent
placements among the arbiters grounds
architecture some even theorize that the
arbiters grounds is actually an
extension of the spirit temple itself
the patterns that link spinner ride upon
often take the shape of a spiral like a
coiled serpent which the spirit temple
also features predominantly the
prisoners that were exiled in arbiters
grounds like Ganondorf were sent to the
underworld via a relic that enables
one-way trips to the Twilight Realm
known as the mirror of Twilight it's
also speculated that this mirror from
Ocarina of Time which is used to
complete the dungeon and access the
final boss may actually be the same
mirror since they do bear some
resemblances of shape and size to each
other they don't look exactly alike but
this could be simply due to the
progression of time or even the newer
consoles is updated graphical quality
enabling the Twilight Princess Art team
to make things look a bit prettier
outside the entrance to the spirit
temple in the area that's also known as
the desert Colossus if link fills the
dried Oasis with water via the song of
storms it's revealed to be a fairy
fountain wouldn't you know it there's
also a fairy fountain very close by the
arbiters grounds ruins in breath of the
wild the grounds were also notorious for
its many paranormal spirits and demons
that haunt its hallways making its
sphere Temple origins even more
plausible it's also possible that the
arbiters grounds was built at the same
time as the spirit temple in conjunction
with one another but link was simply not
able to access it in ocarina of time due
to the major parts of the desert being
inaccessible during a sandstorm the same
kind of storm which appears in breath of
the wild when link strays too far from
the main area with its origins in mind
let's talk about what may have happened
to this ancient prison
it's a No
in fact that the Gerudo have always been
not completely villainous in ocarina of
time they separated themselves from the
hylians due to differences of religion
but would still intermarry with highly
and men in order for their tribe to live
on they only really turned villainous
when their prophetically born King
Ganondorf led them in his efforts
against the royal family of Hyrule
because you know he was their king but
even then they refused to kill link if
he's caught trespassing on Gerudo
territory but rather elect to simply
throw him in prison doesn't seem too
evil to me it's also revealed in-game to
link when he speaks with Nibiru in the
spirit temple who just so happens to be
Ganondorf second-in-command by the way
that Ganondorf did not represent the
hearts of all the Gerudo and was even
seen as cruel to some namely Nibiru who
was planning to overthrow the King of
Thieves
after link proves himself to the Gerudo
they cease being hostile towards him at
all fast forward to breath of the wild
and their hostilities are non-existent
well unless you're a man caught inside
their town possibly even if you're a
Gerudo man but you know rules are rules
it's not like they kill you if you're
caught anyway so why am i saying all
this well I'm making a point that the
Gerudo have never been evil and it was
probably a really heartbreaking ordeal
when their prophesied child king
Ganondorf was revealed to actually be a
you know possessed by the timeless
incarnation of evil bent on the
destruction of the goddesses talk about
staining the Gerudo name this is why or
Bosa who was not alive to meet Ganondorf
personally still had this to say about
him
[Music]
I like that now I can take this person
the garuda have also gone from expecting
and accepting into their people group a
male child once every century to
blatantly barring any and all males from
entrance into their community they have
allegedly sworn off even Garuda men for
the crimes Ganondorf committed also
while they used to be shown to worship a
possibly different goddess the sand
goddess the fact that there is now a
line of champions of the royal family
that is in fact Gerudo means they
probably worship the same god is's as
zelda and the other champions probably
with the spirit temple and arbiters
grounds whether they're separate or the
same thing representing not only the old
ways of the Gerudo who worshiped the
wrong goddess but also being an eternal
reminder of the very same spot where
Ganondorf murdered the sage of water and
just you know Ganondorf in general I
think the Gerudo destroyed at the
arbiters grounds leaving behind only a
couple of ruins in the entrance maybe as
a small final reminder to never again
fall as they once did
the Gerudo are a strong and proud tribe
who have no room for weakness so it
makes sense that they would rid
themselves of the monument to their sins
but what do you think what happened to
the arbiters grounds are the Gerudo
behind its destruction or something else
let me know in the comments below thank
you all so very much for watching I hope
everyone's having a good holiday season
I know I am huge thanks as always to my
amazing patrons including a few new
names
Aven kuru grizzly mane and aura are new
to my elite supporter list so you guys
thank you so much if you're interested
in getting your name up here at the end
of all my videos and joining the elite
of the elite follow the link in the
description below
also I'm on Twitter now so that's a
thing if you want to be in touch with me
a little bit closer than just here on
YouTube and here whatever weird thoughts
pop into my mind like this one for
instance follow me at bandit Nintendo or
click the link in the description below
also down there is the link to my
discord page so you know plenty of
options to connect more if you want to I
think that's all I've got for you guys
today so as always I hope you have a
great rest of your day
yep actually I hope you have a great
rest of your year I don't think I'm
gonna be uploading another video before
2020 so here's to a fantastic 2019 we've
all shared together and an even better
2020 to come you guys have been great so
happy new year
and I hope to see you all then
[Music]